Hello everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Connors, and we are going to talk about the detoxification
pathway genes.
These are super important, especially for those who have had a cancer diagnosis because
what is cancer, cancer is something getting inside the cell, and, in fact, the nucleus
is disrupted in the replication pathway, and now the cell is in the rapid replication.
That's what, by the very definition, is what cancer is.
So when we talk about causes for cancer, we really have to look at detoxification pathways
because the inability to get rid of things that we're exposed to, whether we breathe
them in, whether we inject them in our body, whether we consume them, and it goes across
our gut border, things that pass across any one of our borders that have to be gotten rid
of.
So they have to be detoxified.
So, if things aren't being detoxified either, intercellally, through my kidneys, through
my skin, through my liver, mainly, then they are becoming a part of us, and they tend to
settle inside cells, and then they'll just sit there, and you can live to 120, you'd have
no problem, but if it causes dysfunction to the replication cycle, then you're going
to have a rapid replication, and that's what cancer is, but it could cause other things.
It could cause damage to the cell membranes, it could cause damage to the receptors, and
it's basically every single disease known to man has to do with cellular dysfunction.
So if it's causing any sort of cellular interruption that we need to address it.
So from a genetic standpoint, it behooves us to look at that because if I have defects in
my genetics on the enzymes or the genes that create enzymes that help with detox pathways,
then I'm going to have already a hindrance of function there.
So that's why we need to look at it.
So let's start by looking at the glutathione pathway.
So glutathione is what are your main intercellular detoxification pathways, and I think bedlid and
seeking health for this chart.
So this is called the Transalpheration of the CBS pathway.
It is essential for detoxified sulfites and sulfate groups, and demodia and glutamate, but
we're not going to talk about that here.
The CBS pathway also feeds down this way to create glutathione.
And glutathione is then recycled, and it has to do with all these little bubbles.
These are little abbreviated names for different genes.
So glutathione that is released through a pathway that's not on here called your Keepwood and
your DIRF-2 pathway.
A lot of information about this, these pathways, you probably heard of DIRF-2, you probably heard
of glutathione, you probably heard of superoxide disputease if you've been doing any research
on detoxification and such.
So your Keep-1, your DIRF-2, your glutathione, your superoxide disputease and your catalyzed
pathways are the main ones that we're going to talk about that relate to this chart, then
we're going to look at some other ones as well.
So we make glutathione, we recycle it, we hold it in place with the DIRF-2 and the Keep-1
pathway.
And then along with catalyzed and superoxide disputease is how we get rid of intracellular
toxins, mainly superoxide ions and peroxiditrate ions, these are free radicals.
So free radicals can damage our cell membranes, free radicals can cause cancer, there's more
research on peroxiditrate and heart disease and cancer, as well as new research that's
coming out for Alzheimer's and dementia with peroxiditrate.
So these pathways are very important even if we don't have cancer.
So we want to look at them.
So let's look at these from a genetic standpoint.
So this person or sample patient doesn't really have a lot of defects on our initial piece
on how we make glutathione.
So the CTH, all these genes that we're going to look at here have to do with this pathway
right here.
So let's look at that.
So yes, they have a few defects in there, maybe some hindrance possibly, nothing there, that's
real good.
Some issues here, some issues here, but overall I've seen a lot worse.
So comparing it to a lot of people in my patient base, which are mainly cancer patients,
this is actually quite good.
So not a huge hindrance here.
Now we've got to look at glutathione as being made, but is it being released in order to work
to get rid of this stuff?
So that is the dearth to the keep one gene.
So we scroll down some more, and let's skip that piece right there for a second.
We'll come back to that.
Here's the dearth to the keep one genes, and here's where the person has a lot of issues.
These keep one genes, maybe arguably some of the most important to this whole pathway here,
and this person has defects on all three of those genes right there.
The dearth to they got defects on what, five of the seven there.
So definitely some issues that we may want to support keep one and dearth to for the release
of glutathione.
So I would definitely, I checked those two products that we may use for this, remember we're
not treating the steps, but we do need to support the function of that pathway.
Scroll back up here a little bit right here, because this is where we see a major problem with
this individual.
This is their SOD genes, three genes that are the most important, and they have defects on
all three of those genes.
That's this one right here.
So SOD stands for Super Oxide Disputease, and it grabs onto Super Oxide ion and prevents
it from combining with uncoupled nitric oxide to make peroxiditrate, and this is the big
bad guy that can cause all sorts of problems.
So we need to get rid of this.
This is made by our body, but it's supposed to have a very short half-life, and our body's
supposed to gobble it up with the enzyme Super Oxide Disputease made by this gene right here.
But when we have a genetic picture that looks like this where they got defects on all three
of those genes, they're going to make maybe a little bit less SOD, maybe produce a lot
more peroxiditrate, maybe increase one's risk for all sorts of diseases.
So we want to support this.
Super Oxide Disputease breaks that down into hydrogen peroxide, which if glutathione is released
adequately, which we saw this person had to keep one defect, so we want to support that.
And if they don't have any catalyst defects, that's where it breaks down into water, and we
pee it out into the toilet.
However, this person has a number of catalyst defects too, so something else we may want to
support.
The thing about this software, again, is what we can look at, oh, well, it's 49% of the
people have that defect, and 49% of the people have that defect, and 42% of the people have
that defect, but how about overall, we can click on this little button and see where they
rake as far as the need of the population, and again, this is 25,000 people in this software
is not the healthy cohort study.
These are people that are ill, that are running this test.
Well, really, a healthy need would be somewhere over here, and we never really want to be to
the right of this need.
This person is fairly far to the right of this need, but I've seen people with 222 here,
so it can't get worse, but having defects at all of those is definitely going to be a significant
piece to this person's puzzle, at least that we want to look at.
So that's the G defects that can hinder the detoxification of free radicals, reactive
oxygen species, peroxidite trait, and those are a very cellular damaging products.
Now you get into mainly liver, cytochrome P450 pathway defects, and this doesn't look
quite so bad for a person, and this ABP1G defect, I talk a lot about this in other videos
about how this is your main pathway for getting rid of non-steerinal hit and inflammatory
drugs and some other drugs.
People that have a two on that pathway, I really have a long chat about not taking any
Tylenol and valentines things like that, because those are the people that could have acute
liver failure because of that, this person wouldn't have to worry so much about that.
The POD1 pathway is a key pathway for me when I look at cancer patients, because this is
how you get rid of, I know the software here says pesticides, but it's really large chemicals,
pesticides, insecticides, and they're everywhere, even if you're trying to eat a completely
organic diet, you're still exposed to those things.
But this is the pathway that you get rid of, vaccine ingredients, different medications,
large chemicals that you're exposed to.
So very important pathway, a matter of fact I put on the website video, just on the POD1 pathway
and how important it is, not only in the liver, but through the bloodstream intracellally
and intracellally, the POD1 pathway, the gene that's made through this pathway, is super
important with cancer.
The NAT pathway, one and two, are also important to detoxify medications.
So this is a very important pathway for cancer patients as well.
Remember, anything that gets inside the cell that disrupts replication cycles are at cause
for cancer.
So we want to get rid of things that we're exposed to.
Yes, we want to decrease our exposure that has to do with lifestyle changes, but we
want to help improve these pathways that could cause problems.
And we have to talk briefly about the MTHFR gene because this is another piece here of detoxification,
and this person has a two, one of the two MTHFR genes.
So definitely, this person we want to support some liver detox pathways and cellular detox
pathways, products that we choose to petapod, test eat, and other variables that we look
at as well as the person's diet.
So as a holistic approach, as we possibly could take, make sure you watch the other videos
of this series too, and we will talk again very soon.